how is your daughter uh not great not
great so she as you know went to the ER
now twice so everyone knows she went
once last week and then you know she
went a couple days ago Tori Spelling
opens up about her 14 year old daughter
Stella's recent Health Battle and
reveals her diagnosis it's better to
just tell the truth the actress explains
it all on Sirius xm's Jeff Lewis live
first going into detail about Stella's
hospitalizations
so we rushed her to the ER
um and by the time we got there she was
starting to feel
like she was coming back but it was
really scary I thought she had a she's
14. I'm like how does a 14 year old have
a stroke Tori then shares Stella's
diagnosis and what it entails a
hemiplegic migrate what does that mean
so I didn't know it's basically one side
goes numb it almost kind of mimics what
a stroke would be
so yeah so her left arm went completely
numb she couldn't lift it and then half
of her throat and then her mouth so it
looked like she had had a stroke
according to the American migraine
Foundation a hemiplegic migraine is a
rare kind that affects a person's motor
weaknesses and can impair their speech
and feeling it actually doesn't run my
family I found it it runs in Dean's
family
oh more things to blame him with you
know Stella is Tori's eldest daughter
whom she shares with husband D McDermott
there are also parents to Liam Hattie
Finn and Beau I'm definitely way
outnumbered like I always am like I can
do it I can do everything and then I'm
like oh my gosh Dean I need help like
someone carry the baby like it's hard
unfortunately it's been a rough season
of Health for the family Tori was
hospitalized last month right before the
holidays she shared this selfie from her
hospital bed and explained she was
experiencing dizziness and trouble
breathing I learned at a young age to be
like okay
just keep going fast forward to the new
year and Stella takes not one but two
trips to the ER Tory posted this pic of
her daughter just last week I feel like
life is too short and we we forget that
though I think because life keeps going
and so you say to yourself I gotta make
plans with this person I gotta make an
effort and then you don't because your
life keeps going and it's important now
to really take that time and I think I'm
starting to finally get that Stella has
since returned home and it seems like
the family is in better spirits as Dean
and Tori took their eldest kids to a
concert over the weekend and as far as
how Stella's medical issues go she's
still getting treatment still dizzy
she's nauseous
um the migraine broke they broke it each
time she went to the ER but she's still
so she's going to a neurologist at
Children's Hospital La
foreign